THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> NEW LEGAL CHALLENGES.
THE FEDERAL GRAND JURY INDICTING
BANNON.
THE FAILURE AND REFUSAL FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION ENCOURAGING THE
RALLY THAT RETURNED FROM THE
RIOT.
BASED OFF OF WHAT HE SAID THE
DAY BEFORE.
>> ALL HELL IS GOING TO BREAK
LOOSE TOMORROW.
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO SAID IF I WAS
IN REVOLUTION, I WOULD BE IN
WASHINGTON WITH TRENTON.
THIS IS FOR YOUR TIME IN
HISTORY.
>> FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS
PLAYING A VERY SIMILAR GAME.
REFUSING TO SHOW UP FOR A
DEPOSITION YESTERDAY.
ISSUING 35 SUBPOENAS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CAPITOL
RIOT.
SOME CLOSEST ALLIES AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
SO TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT
EXACTLY BANNON IS CHARGED WITH.
>> THINGS GOT REAL.
TWO DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS FOR
FAILING TO APPEAR FOR A
DEPOSITION AND REFUSING TO HAND
OVER DOCUMENTS.
NOW FACING A POTENTIAL MAXIMUM
OF ONE YEAR IN PRISON FOR EACH
COUNT.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN AND HOW DID
WE GET HERE?
SUBPOENAED IN OCTOBER AND REALLY
THUMBED HIS NOSE.
THE MAYOR GARLAND RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE TO INDICT
BANNON AND NOW HIS FUTURE IS
UNCERTAIN.
>> DO WE KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHAT
INFORMATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WANT?
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO ASK AND
GET FROM THESE SUBPOENAS?
>> THEY WANT TO KNOW ABOUT MORE
OF HIS CONTACT WITH TRUMP
LEADING UP TO THAT DAY AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT DAY MORE
FROM THE WILLARD HOTEL WAR ROOM.
YESTERDAY'S NEWS SURELY
INCREASED THOSE CHANCES.
>> REALLY A BIG DEVELOPMENT
WE'LL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REPORTING
LET'S GET REACTION NOW FROM THE
INDICTMENT ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
LAWMAKERS AND WHAT COULD THIS
POTENTIALLY MEAN FOR MARK
MEADOWS.
>> HE VERY QUICK TO REACT SAYING
THIS SENDS A STRONG MESSAGE TO
ANY OTHER WITNESSES THE
COMMITTEE CALLS ON WHO REFUSE TO
COMPLY WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
YOU MENTIONED MARK MADE OWES.
YESTERDAY, HE WAS SUPPOSED TO
HAVE A VEST GAGS.
ASKED TO TURNOVER KEY DOCUMENTS.
AS A RESULT, THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN BENNY THOMPSON SAW THIS
COMING THURSDAY NIGHT AND MOVED
FORWARD WITH POSSIBLY REFERRING
MARK MEADOWS AND OVER WHAT COULD
HAPPEN WITH STEVE BANNON AND
MIGHT BE THE ONLY WITNESS WHO
GOES THROUGH THE PROCESS.
STEVE BANNON'S INDICTMENT
SHOULDN'T SEND A CLEAR MESS
OTHER TO ANYONE TRYING TO STONE
WALL.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
OTHER MEMBERS ALSO REACTED THIS
IS WHAT SHE SAID IN A TWEET.
THE GRAND JURY INDICTED BANNON.
LET THIS SEND A MESSAGE TO ALL
OF THOSE WHO WOULD ATTACK OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THE DAYS ARE OVER WE WILL EXPOSE
THOSE INVOLVED.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
CALLING THIS INVESTIGATION A
SHAM.
THE TWO MODERATE REPUBLICANS WHO
WERE STRONG CRITICS OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS SHOWS A STRONG MESSAGE TO
ANY WITNESSES WHO REFUSE TO
COMPLY.
THEY HAVE THE PROCESS BEHIND
THEM.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS A
VERY STRONG MESSAGE TO THOSE WHO
WOULD COOPERATE.
>> BRINGING IN THE LEGAL ANALYST
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD JOIN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HE REFUSED TO
APPEAR.
REFUSED TO HAND OVER DOCUMENTS.
IF YOU WERE ON THE DEFENSE TEAM,
WHAT WOULD KEEP HIM FROM GETTING
CONVICTED?
>> HE DOESN'T NEED TO MOUNT A
DEFENSE.
IT IS HIS RIGHT TO NOT REBUT
CHARGES AT ALL.
A VERY INTERESTING CASE TO START
WITH.
HE WASN'T A GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE
AT THE
TIME.
NO, HE DOES NOT HAVE A
PARTICULAR STRONG LEGA
L
ARGUMENT.
AT THE TIME WHERE THE PRESIDENT
COULD EXERT WITH THEM.
BANNON WAS OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE IN 2017.
I WILL BE CANDID THAT MARK
MEADOWS HAS A BETTER CASE WITH
BOTH.
THE OTHER PERSON YOU IDENTIFIED
THERE, JEFFERY CLARK CAME IN AND
PROVIDED ABOUT AN HOUR OF
ANSWERS BUT STILL COMPLIED WITH
THE SUBPOENA.
IT WILL BE VERY HARD THE LAW
REQUIRES YOU TO RESPOND.
MEADOWS IS A DIFFERENT CASE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WILL HAVE A
STRONGER PRESIDENTIAL CLAIM.
YOU NEED TO COME IN AND ON THE
ACCOUNT OF THAT FACT.
IN OPEN DEFIANCE OF THE SUBPOENA
FOR THE CALL TO HAVE TO MAKE.
>> DEMOCRATS WOULD BE VOCAL IN
WANTING TO BE PROACTIVE AND MAKE
THESE SUBPOENAS TO CARRY WEIGHT.
THE SOURCES DIDN'T THINK THAT
THIS WAS SUCH A SIMPLE CHOICE.
WHAT DOES THE WHOLE PROCESS TELL
YOU ABOUT GARLAND AND THE WAY
HE'S BEEN RUNNING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT OUGHT TO CARRY WEIGHT AND
TO STEP IN TO ENFORCE THEM.
IT IS JUST NOT GOING TO BE
EFFICIENT TO CHARGE EVERY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO VIOLATES A
SUBPOENA.
IN THE JEFFERY CLARK EXAMPLE,
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T COME IN
AND ANSWER A LOT.
SOMETIMES THEY COME IN AND GIVE
SOME DOCUMENTS AND NOT OTHERS.
FRANKL